in the celebration of Christmas local
tourists and people who live here in Las
Vegas you can take a look attending Mass
here in the biggest celebration in the
Catholic church now here at Guardian
Angel Church there will be a Christmas
concert starting at 11 30 p.m that's
what people are currently waiting for
followed by a midnight mass over at
Saint Anne Catholic Church on Maryland
Parkway their doors opened earlier with
the most recent Mass taking place at 10
pm and across the world Pope Francis
giving Christmas Eve Mass at the Vatican
the churchgoers in Las Vegas Sharon why
it's important to them to attend mass
tonight along with Bishop Gordon of
Guardian Angel Church sharing some words
tomorrow we're going to open gifts and
people are going to forget for two or
three hours what it's really about and
you know you really want to remember
that it's not just about the gifts it's
about keeping Christ in your heart Las
Vegas is a 24-hour town
so this is uh I think this is a perfect
way for us to let the world know that
we're called to pray
all the time throughout throughout the
day I anticipate that the cathedral will
be full and the faith will be very much
palpable
since the start of the pandemic large
Gatherings have been minimized but this
year with Christmas falling on a Sunday
capacity is expected to be high this
church being very popular amongst
tourists since it's right along the
strip again the choir of the cathedral
will be leading the concert in carols
that's set to begin at 11 30. of course
that's what people are sitting here
waiting for reporting live Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now